conservative punted Ann Coulter has occasionally
been critical of Donald Trump and she is now
calling for Trump to go what pushed her over
the edge.
Trump saying that some of the kids who were
brought to the United States by their undocumented
immigrant parents are no angels except what
she's mad about is not that Trump is going
after innocent kids. It's that Trump is saying
that they might be allowed to stay if he gets
his way. This is actually interesting because
when you look at the tweet that she quoted
and sent out, it's not obvious whether she's
angry that Trump is attacking kids or angry
that Trump is going to allow the kids to stay,
but when you look at it and you understand
Ann Coulter, it makes more sense. Donald Trump
tweeted yesterday quote, many of the people
in DACA, no longer very young, are far from
angels. Some are very tough hardened criminals.
President Obama said he had no legal right
to sign order, but would anyway if Supreme
court remedies with overturn a deal will be
made with Dems for them to stay.
So most people saw that tweet and they were
disgusted that Donald Trump was going after
children who are in the U S through no fault
of their own by calling them no angels and
tough hardened criminals and Coulter Coke
quoting Donald Trump's tweets and adding quote,
okay, that does it. I give up. They can stay.
You must go. Might suggest to you that she's
angry that Trump is calling these kids criminals
and that they're no angels. That's not the
right interpretation. Ann Coulter is apparently
upset that Trump is saying DACA recipients
will be allowed to stay in the United States.
She's been tweeting anti DACA amnesty messages.
She wants Trump to be more aggressive on this
issue of immigration. Stunningly as if Trump
hasn't done enough damage already. So this
is an example of a disaffected right winger,
but it's kind of the opposite of many. Lots
of Republicans are disgusted with Trump going
too far in many cases against the constitution,
against the rule of law.
Culture is the opposite. She's upset. Trump
isn't hardline enough on immigration, but
still any prominent disaffected right winger
with Trump who publicly says so is a little
crack in the armor. I used that term earlier
in the show and I'm using it again. We don't
know what might make any right-wing or opt
to stay home in November of 2020 are vote
for someone else. And it crazy as it sounds
to us to follow Ann Coulter's lead on anything.
Some people actually respect her. I know it's
shocking and they might decide based on what
she says, not to vote for Donald Trump. So
we'll take all of it and meanwhile we will
push our strategy of a get out the vote and
everything else that we've been discussing,
uh, and see where it gets us in November of